[Music]
they've depressed you they've inspired
you and they let out you ha ha now
Warner Brothers in DC are back to just
completely overwhelm you
what is happening Aquaman remember
Aquaman the nerd that talks to fish I am
talking with fishes of no help Wonder
Woman well he's gone from zero to hunky
hero watch as the pure charisma of Jason
Momoa supercharges the character
transforming him into a sexy undersea
Superman who's super fast super strong a
lot of the time and mostly invulnerable
okay so his powers are kind of
inconsistent but so what everyone knows
that this Aquaman's real powers the
smolder
[Music]
listen to come aboard permission granted
sailor I mean is it hot in here who
strap it as Arthur Currie embarks on a
reluctant quest to become King Arthur
but you know like the cool version I
give you King Arthur and he's not alone
here to help our princess mera and his
mother Queen Atlanta two powerful women
struggling to overcome terrible wigs
together they'll hunt for a mythical
Trident that will mark him as the one
true king by giving him his comic book
accurate costume holy crap he actually
makes that dumb orange and green suit
look cool hail to the king baby did you
think there was a lot going on in
Avengers infinity war will hold this
man's beer because Thanos may have
brought you chaos in the cosmos but
Aquaman is a whirlwind of so many
locations the movie added titles to keep
track from Amnesty Bay to the Boston
aquarium over the Sahara enroute to
Italy to somewhere in the Atlantic Ocean
to somewhere in the Indian Ocean from
Atlantis to the hidden see whatever the
kingdom of the brain is and a bunch of
other underwater places all while living
through massive undersea battle
featuring Knights on sea horses fighting
mermaids and crab men in between scenes
of overly complicated game of Thrones
politics we honor you King Darius by
inviting Zeb to be the first Kingdom to
join King ORMs alliance I said you had a
choice Volk oh my lord you need four of
the Seven Kingdoms to send an attack
once you've obtained the pledge to the
while still making time for any energy
owns adventures a Little Mermaid love
story a port view with high-tech pirates
and that's before taking a quick lap in
the dinosaur field core of the earth
something that guides you in bringing
peace to the world wait what happened I
think about go so get ready to jump the
shark all of the sharks and then shoot
at those sharks with water powered
plasma cannons
a movie so packed to the gills it
couldn't just tell one Aquaman story it
had to tell all of them at once
forcing director James Wan to start
pumping out aqua Jason spin-offs to buy
some time to figure out how the heck
he's gonna top this bonkers thing and if
I might make a suggestion maybe a
prequel about how this octopus learn to
play the drums not quite my tempo
downbeat on 18 rushing here we go
story Jacques Cousteau Murr lady marine
goblin Eric fish monger Atlanta Shengo
wet if he Thrones dethrones war machine
rap people crab people semen
come on we had to cut Julie Andrews
Patrick Wilson yelling
[Applause]
[Music]
and explosive interruptions legend has
it that one day a new king woke up his
loyalty is to the school the clue to add
lands final resting place now come on
how all the new explosions really
enterprise
the waterboy okay look I know people
think this is similar to another comic
book movie where two ideologically
opposed family members clash over the
kingship of a hit-and high-tech
civilization but hear me out
this one is underwater I'm not a scroll
honestly I'm going to bed before either
one of you comes up with another clever
idea to get us killed or worse expelled
my name is Peter porker and for 22 years
I've been the incredible spider-ham
scooby-doo where are you